and five two three two one
good morning everyone and welcome to the
institute for government welcome to
everyone here in person and those of you
joining us online I'm Hannah White I'm
director of The Institute of government
and I'm delighted to welcome you here
today for this keynote speech via
Vancouver MP who is of course Shadow
executive States for the home office
uh following the secretary indeed and a
vet is going to be talking to us today
about how labor would approach a climate
policing and running the home office we
will be live creating from ifg events
using the hashtag ISD home office so
please follow along if you wish to we'll
have a video at sound recording on our
website very shortly after the event and
if you're watching online please do
start sending in your questions via
sliding
of course if that needs introduction but
is has of course been labor MP as the
1997 and before her appointment is
Charlotte Home Secretary she was a chair
and home Affairs select committee and in
government she served a secretary of
state to work with pensions Chief
Secretary of Treasury and housing
investor so I'm sure we're all very
interested to hear what the best event
has to pay for today thank you
thank you very much Hannah and thank you
to the ifg for hosting me today thank
you too to all of you for coming this
morning and I also just thought I was
welcoming the work that the institute
for government does through thick and
thin to promote protector government
boy do we need that right now and I
welcome to patreon to the work of the
ifg academy who offer advice and support
to every newly appointed cabinet to
minister and Minister as they start
their new job also had a very busy 12
months with hundreds of newly appointed
or reappointed reshuffled ministers and
that's 12 months alone we've had
Three Justice secretaries two of whom
were the same person three attorney
generals and four police
and it is a shocking level of chaos and
it's damaging
but it's not just the chaos and the
incompetence that has caused the
problems around issues around crime and
policing so I want to talk today about
what's been a complete collapse in home
office leadership on crime and policing
under the conservatives how they stood
back while neighborhood policing has
crumbled while the charge rate has
plummeted well confidence and policing
and the criminal justice system have
fallen
while more victims are being let down
and more criminals are getting off
and I want to set out the very different
labor approach that KIA stammer and I
and the labor Shadow cabinet are taking
and show why only labor is the party of
Law and Order now
if you talk to people across the country
about their experiences of crime
policing and the criminal justice system
you'll hear countless stories of
frustration and anger
too often there is a sense that when
things go wrong no one comes and nothing
is done
too often as in so many other public
services after 13 years of conservative
government Everything feels broken
so I've heard from shop owners and
residents who were sick and tired of
nothing being done about Rising crime
and anti-social behavior in their Town
centers that is dragging the area and
the local economy down
I've heard from a taxi driver who told
me about the local taxi rank being
pelted routinely with Stones by a small
group of teenagers but nothing being
done
an older woman who told me that she
didn't shop in town anymore because the
street drinkers made her say and feel
unsafe and she never saw the police
and a store manager who said they've
been burgled three times in the space of
a fortnight and even though they thought
they knew who was responsible no one had
been to be able to see the CCTV
policing is overstretched But Rising
crime and anti-social behavior in town
centers is corroding the local social
and economic fabric and the police
patrols have been cut back
I've heard two from parents deeply
worried about what's happening to
children and teenagers about them being
bullied or harassed in the street
threatened with violence or drawn into
crime or being targeted or groomed
online
and they're also worried most of all
that if things start going wrong for
their family there will be no one to
turn to or no one to help
we lost two more young lives to violence
terrible violence this week in Cheshire
and in Chelmsford
a knife crime has gone up by 70 since
2015 with some of the biggest increases
in the suburbs and in small towns yet
early intervention services have been
cut back and again too little is being
done
and I've heard from pensioners worried
not just about anti-social behavior on
the streets but about being targeted
with scams and online fraud and fraud
and early accounts now for nearly half
of all crime yet barely any of those
crimes are actually investigated and
less than 0.1 percent of them make it to
court so hardly anything is being done
and all of us have spoken to women who
are fed up of holding their keys between
their fingers as they walk home in the
dark who are weary of having to worry
about whether their drink is being
spiked and who are angry that so little
is done to support them or get them
Justice when things go wrong
today across the country 300 women are
likely to be raped 200 of those rapes
will be reported but barely three of
those rapists will be convicted
so let that disgraceful fact sink in
shamefully little is being done
and remember how much more Angry
everyone feels to see that basic
standards of behavior towards women
haven't even been enforced within the
very police forces who are supposed to
protect us from violence
over the last 30 years traditional
volume crimes like robbery and burglary
have fallen as new technology like home
alarms car anti-theft devices have made
a huge difference and that is really
welcome
but as long as people feel that in
important areas like knife crime or Town
Center anti-social Behavior things are
getting worse and as long as people feel
that vital Public Services won't protect
them or deliver Justice then confidence
will fall and the sense of public
frustration and anger will grow
after 13 years of conservative
government fewer crimes are being sold
fewer criminals are being caught there
will be around 7 000 thefts today in
England Wells of which around 4 000 will
be reported only 180 will face Court
since 2010 under the conservatives we've
seen arrests halved prosecutions halved
convictions half Community penalties
half court delays at record highs and
record numbers of victims giving up on
the criminal justice system and dropping
out and the prosecution rate has
plummeted by a shocking two-thirds since
2015 with only one in 20 recorded crimes
now charge so quite literally that means
more criminals are getting away with it
after 13 years of conservative
government and the Home Secretary is
doing nothing to turn that around
that collapse in prosecution started in
2015 successive home secretaries have
just Shrugged their shoulders and failed
to act
on policing the Home Secretary is absent
too
across the country I have met dedicated
and brave police officers who are doing
a brilliant job to keep people safe
neighborhood officers and pcsios I spoke
to yesterday in Milton Keynes who are
working incredibly hard to tackle knife
crime which has risen sharply in the
area
response officers that I've spoken to in
Yorkshire
who risk their own lives to stop a
dangerous machete attacker or the
detectives in merseyside I spoke to
working night and day to solve and
investigate homicide and organized crime
but for all that dedication and hard
work public confidence in policing has
fallen and according to some surveys by
20 percent in just two years
forces are facing growing and more
complex demands but they have fewer
resources and badly inadequate policies
to help them cope
austerity has been a double whammy for
them the 20 000 officers and thousands
more pcsos and staff that were cut but
other Cuts hitting public hitting
policing too for example in prevention
probation prosecutors Youth Services
drug and alcohol treatment social care
the NHS all run into the ground and
policing picks up the pieces when other
services fail
so mental health Demand on policing has
shot up
and sadly you will often see police
officers set sat waiting for hours
trying to get serious mental health
patients admitted before they hurt
themselves or someone else picking up
the pieces for the strain in the NHS
at the same time crime has become more
complex whether that be dealing with
Rising floor fraud or online evidence in
abuse cases but policing technology and
practice hasn't kept up
the police national computer that wants
state of the art technology and ahead of
the game is an unbelievable 50 years old
next year
digital forensics is a total nightmare
officers are spending hours more on
bureaucracy especially if they want to
lay charges one officer I spoke to said
he now spends 12 hours player preparing
the same case File that would have taken
him just two hours two years ago
and there's huge Workforce problems a
major shortage of detectives many
officers feeling badly overstretched and
unsupported while training and
recruitment processes are inadequate
as the truly shocking cases of David
Carrick and Wayne cousins have shown
vettings standards and misconduct
systems have badly failed none neither
of those men should ever have been
police officers or able to serve for so
long
but systems to root out racism misogyny
homophobic yeah and toxic bullying
culture are nowhere near strong enough
letting victims communities and policing
down
and confidence has fallen further in
Black communities too
all this is deeply damaging but again
where is the home secretary's plan to
turn this around where's the action to
upgrade police technology or deliver a
proper National Workforce strategy why
isn't anyone showing National leadership
to sort out the really wasteful lack of
coordination between 43 forces on shared
services technology procurement where's
the plan for a new standards regime why
why did the home office not act after
the awful murder of Sarah everard when
everyone demanded change and why isn't
the Home Secretary working with the
health secretary on reducing mental
health pressures or with the education
secretary on plans to prevent still
Rising knife crime
it's a dereliction of Duty
the conservatives are missing an action
in the fight against Crime
but I want to talk about what underpins
this because it's not just about one
Home Secretary for 13 years the
conservatives deliberately ran hands-off
home office failing to take proper
action on serious areas of rising crime
failing to introduce serious policing
reform
conservatives ministers obviously made
the decisions to hit policing
prosecution on the courts hard with
austerity which caused deep damage to
those services but then they also walked
away
under David Cameron and Theresa May
conservatives made a strategic decision
to withdraw the home office from active
policies on policing and crime and to
leave everything instead to a very
fragmented network of local forces pccs
and weak national policing institutions
and successive home secretaries have
made the same maintained the same
approach ever since
it has been a laissez-faire approach
that in practice has let communities
down
so they abandoned the work that the home
office used to do on police standards on
workforce planning on crime prevention
on anticipating new and changing
patterns of crime and they ditched
partnership working with other Leaders
with other departments or agencies even
where that National leadership is needed
that's why there's no proper National
Workforce plan or why technology is in
such chaos
and they've totally failed to deliver a
policing and justice system fit for the
2020s there's no sense of direction or
urgency about the challenges policing
and communities face
but too often well there's been from the
conservative home secretaries is
rhetoric the talk is tough but the walk
is woefully weak and the conservatives
are weak on crime and on its causes too
the enact the action
or shall we say inaction
reflects deliberate decisions but also a
deep rigid set of values it reflects the
conservative belief in a smaller
government and in active government
their lack of commitment to Public
Services
and a sense of walking away from their
responsibility for what happens in
communities or whether Justice is
delivered
leaving people to sink or swim alone
and it reflects a shocking carelessness
that the conservative party has shown in
recent years about respect for the rule
of law itself
and I don't think they get how damaging
this has become
because confidence in policing in the
criminal justice system is increasingly
fragile and for some people that is
hanging only by a thread and it matters
it threatens our British policing model
our policing by consent if confidence is
not maintained undermines the respect
for the rule of law which underpins our
very democracy and the safety of our
communities if just people think that
Justice won't be done and it corrodes
our communities if public spaces are
downgraded graded and people don't feel
safe
so that's why labor will take a
fundamentally different approach
in the labor party we believe in
championing social justice you don't get
social justice
if you are denied Justice and you don't
feel safe
we want Britain to be a country in which
everyone can enjoy new opportunities but
security is the foundation on which all
other opportunities are built
strong communities are safe communities
and that's why we believe in upholding
the law standing up for justice and
cracking down on the criminals who
destroy people's lives and livelihoods
so we're angry when women don't feel
safe at night or in the streets or in
their homes and we hate the impact that
it has on our town centers and we want
to write those injustices unlike the
conservatives we believe in active
government we believe in high quality
public services and we want more police
but we will expect higher standards from
from them and will work in partnership
with other government departments and
agencies
and we believe in those core peel
principles on which our British policing
model was founded nearly 200 ago years
ago a model for which we should be proud
that the purpose of policing is to
prevent crime and disorder to uphold the
law pursue Justice for victims and keep
communities safe and strong
policing by consent where the police are
the public and the public are the police
so kirstama as head of the crown
prosecution service prosecuted serious
criminals and terrorists stood up for
victims and their families and time and
again he's shown leadership in upholding
the rule of law
for 25 years I've worked on different
aspects of crime Justice Public Safety
National Security from the very first
briefings I ever received from MI5 and
MI6 as a member of the intelligence and
security committee a quarter of a
century ago through to being a courts
Minister and Shadow Home Secretary and
select committee chair so care and I
have both seen the challenges the home
office faced but we know how much more
it could be doing to serve our country
now
so labor will bring in new reforms to
policing to rebuild confidence and help
tackle some of those persistent
challenges we Face
reintroducing new work on crime
prevention and policing standards into
the home office
most urgently we will introduce new
mandatory requirements on vetting
standards training and misconduct
underpinned by new legislation
it means new leadership from a labor
home office to set out active strategies
in vital areas including violence
against women and girls on fraud on
youth violence and on anti-social
behavior and we will work not just with
the police and Criminal Justice System
but with councils Community groups
businesses the NHS schools and the
voluntary sector
and it means right reforms right across
the criminal justice system so more
criminals can be charged and punished
while more victims get Justice
and yes serious leadership too on
overhauling technology so the police can
use modern equipment and proper
collaboration and procure on procurement
and efficiency across 43 forces
we'll develop a proper National
Workforce strategy too
to support the police but also raise
standards
and at the heart of our plans on crime
and policing we'll be rebuilding and
renewing the neighborhood police who are
at the heart of our communities in the
fight against Crime
and I want to conclude by saying a bit
about why labor is making this such a
priority as part of our reforms
over the last 13 years we've seen
policing become a reactive Christ
response crisis response service
instead of proactive and problem solving
only 12 percent of officers are in
neighborhood policing now compared to 19
in 2010
6 000 neighborhood police and more than
8 000 pcsos have gone since 2015 alone
but the real figures are worse than that
because even where teams have stayed in
place they're often covering bigger
areas they're merging with response
teams and offices are routinely
abstracted from those neighborhood teams
to cover elsewhere sometimes for months
at a time
the people who were the eyes and ears of
policing in communities have gone and
the people who solved local problems are
too often not there
neighborhood policing is always the
thing that gets squeezed when everything
else is overstretched that's why the
Town Center patrols have gone and why
half the country say they never see the
police on patrol anymore a proportion
that has doubled since the conservatives
came to power
but you can't rebuild trust in policing
without rebuilding neighborhood police
you can't build the relationships that
generate intelligence that helps catch
offenders or crack down on local crime
if no one knows who to talk to
neighborhood policing shouldn't be seen
as a Cinderella service it should be the
building block on which the rest of
policing is based not left to the edges
of policing but protected and
prioritized
and there's a good reason why Sir Mark
Rowley the new met commissioner has made
neighborhood policing a critical part of
his plan to restore trust in London
in Yorkshire my constituency and across
the coal Fields after the minor strike
we saw confidence in policing collapse
but it was the neighborhood policing
introduced under a labor government that
rebuilt that in confidence again so that
is why labor will put 13 000 more
neighborhood police and officers and
pcsos back on Britain streets paid for
with 360 million pounds delivered from
our shared procurement plan
we will introduce new neighborhood
police guarantee returns restoring
patrols back to town centers making sure
communities and residents know who to
turn to when things go wrong with new
statutory responsibilities on forces to
protect and deliver neighborhood
policing
so yes bringing officers and pcsos back
into our town centers
bringing them back into our communities
to work on knife crime back into
neighborhood teams working to keep the
streets safe for women at night
and restoring those officers and teams
to pick up that vital intelligence to
catch dangerous criminals drawing on the
traditional core of British policing the
Bobby on the beat but modernized for a
new age equipped with new training and
technology so they can use data to
Target hot spots react quickly and build
Partnerships to solve problems
across the country through the years
I've met inspiring neighborhood officers
and pcsos doing incredible work
the officer who I spoke to was working
with troubled primary school children to
stop them going off the rails and he
knew whose dad was in prison he knew
whose mum had been a victim of domestic
abuse he knew the problems those kids
faced but also what was needed to turn
things around
the pcso who worked with domestic abuse
victims their Port of Call when they
were afraid
Catherine caywood may be fiction
but the stories of police officers like
Catherine who know their communities who
pick up the things that everyone else
misses who solve crimes and keep people
safe are all very real and we need more
of them
so preventing crime keeping people safe
punishing criminals who wreck lives so
victims get Justice protecting
communities from the blight that drags
everyone down an upholding respect for
the law that underpins our democracy
these are the things that labor will do
30 years ago this year the labor Shadow
Home Secretary Tony Blair said our party
will be tough on crime and tough on the
causes of crime it was right then it's
right now it's what we did then it's
what we'll do again
over 13 years the conservatives have let
communities down only labor is the party
of Law and Order now thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you very much Yvette now we'll
take some questions first from
broadcasters we have a roving mic in the
room please say your name and where
you're from then I'll take some
questions that have come through online
and then we'll go back to questions in
the room so Maddie you want to start
with Ben Wright here from the BBC
uh morning Hannah morning a bit
um just two questions please the the
first you talked about the policing
system being very overstretched right
now but want to recruit train pay 13 000
new community offices through efficiency
savings rejigging cash from elsewhere in
the system is that really plausible and
what impact is that going to have on on
broader policing secondly one force
obviously under scrutiny right now is
Lancashire police How concerned are you
about how they've handled The
Disappearance of Nicola bully
particularly their statement yesterday
where they talked about her struggles
with alcohol and the menopause thanks
so first of all we we have set out very
clear proposals for 13 000 additional
police officers and pcsos into
neighborhood teams we've set out a
program of savings from shared
procurement program 360 million pounds
that would pay for the additional
offices that need to be recruited and
that's based on work on the savings that
can be made across police forces they
currently all have different procurement
systems around technology around cars
around equipment all of those kinds of
things and actually our figure is a very
cautious s estimate compared to the
police foundation work who estimated
that double the level of savings could
be made from that shared work but we
will make it mandatory to share services
and procurement in that way which
something that the government has failed
to do so that's why we're confident that
savings can be made but we'll put those
savings back into the neighborhood
policing that we need the mix of police
officers and also pcsos and specials as
well but fundamentally getting 13
000 additional boots on the ground in
those Community teams working with
communities to prevent tackle Crackdown
on crime and we believe that actually
will help policing so Lord Stevens John
Stevens former Metropolitan Police
Commissioner who championed neighborhood
policing under the last Labor government
he did a report for the labor party back
in 2013 2014 which argued that the real
risk was that policing was going to
become more and more reactive instead of
being proactive instead of tackling
problems that's what I think we've seen
happen we've seen policing increasingly
overstretched because they've been
forced into the reactive response and
not enough is being done to Target
demand to deal with the demands on
policing for example on Mental Health
but also to give them the technology and
work with them to help them move work
more effectively rather than coping with
bureaucracy and to make sure that that
proactive policing is in place
on the the issue about um Lancashire
police look Lancashire police have
obviously had discussions with Nicola
Bully's family and I don't know what
those discussions are and I don't know
what discussions have taken place and
I'm very respectful of that obviously I
think there are concerns because the
information that that they set out was
very unusual for them to do so and I
would want to know more from Lancashire
police about the reasons for doing this
I do think the most important thing
right now is to support Nicholas family
and also to support the ongoing
investigation so they can find out
what's happened
thank you could be getting Mick Martin
from the sky please
I think um just an extra question on the
costing it costs about 40 to 60 000
pounds to train a police officer
notwithstanding some of those will be
Community police officers it seems like
that the sums actually do not add up
there and is this a sort of guarantee
that if this if these thirteen or
thirteen thousand officers did come into
play then you wouldn't have to find the
extra money by taxing or cutting
services and just another question on uh
how you propose to pay for those extra
officers it's an awful lot of money to
to find through getting police forces to
work better together and I wonder
whether this reopens up the debate about
how many police forces we have 43 in
England and Wales we've seen it work in
Scotland what's Labor's view about that
debate on is it time now to start
merging police forces in England and
Wales to make things a bit more
efficient
so firstly on the costings what we set
out is 13 000 more boots on the ground
of those we would ring fence 3 000
officers from the additional from the
uplift that the conservatives have
promised we would ring fence three
thousand of those officers to go into
neighborhood teams because at the moment
they're not at the moment even though
the conservatives have talked about
reversing their Cuts it's not going into
neighborhood policing and that's the
point about needing to be proactive not
reactive we would recruit then a further
3 000 police officers on top of that
swiftly on top of that and 4 000 pcsos
as well and then also recruit another 3
000 specials too so we've always been
very clear that this is about mixed
teams with mixed different kinds of
experience to be part of those
neighborhood teams but that's also how
you make neighborhood teams more
effective the 360 million pounds we have
estimated from the savings is actually a
very cautious estimate based on a lot of
the work that's been done by procurement
experts I've spoken to Blue Light
commercial who've talked to me about how
little forces are signing up for example
in many areas to savings that they could
be making and there's a whole range of
areas where they absolutely could be
cutting down on waste and making those
Savings in practice and as I said the
police foundation's estimate was in fact
that the savings would be well over 600
million pounds from these kinds of
programs so our estimate is a very
cautious one we're very clear though
that that was what makes the difference
in getting those police officers back on
the beat using every penny well of
public money spending money while being
clear that everything we announce will
be costed and paid for and that will
make the difference on the issue around
the forces we think you can move very
quickly to just get much better
coordination between them and to have
those partnership workings in place but
to make them mandatory rather than just
voluntary and it really be quite chaotic
to have much more coordination and
collaboration we did set out the Lord
John G Stevens did set out as part of
the independent policing review that he
did into policing various proposals for
reform in 2013-14
some of things have moved on on those
areas since then and so what we're doing
is looking with
um uh the with Chief constables and
former Chief constables at some of the
areas and themes that are looking at
those again but what he was arguing for
then
um it was that process of collaboration
between forces rather than the the
top-down process
thank you could we go to Peter Cardwell
and talk to you well talk TV uh thank
you very much indeed for that very
interesting speech um in terms of the 13
000 neighborhood police officers
obviously you've broken that down in
terms of numbers but still per officer
you're looking at 27 and a half thousand
pounds and that 360 million can you just
illuminate that in terms of is that just
within one year or is that across every
year that those savings will be made
also secondly if it's all right
um in terms of Jeremy corbyn's uh the
decision by kierstormer to exclude
Jeremy corbyn from starting from the
labor party he's called out an attack on
Democracy some of his allies have gone
further and called care starmer a
hypocrite and a liar what do you make of
those comments
so on the the costings we can set out
further detail for you but the 360
million that is the full year cost
that's a full Year's worth of savings so
it's you know obviously you make savings
each year from making those changes and
bear in mind as well the different costs
around training for police officers and
pcsos that we've taken all into account
and the existing budget that the
government has already set out for the
uplift too so taking all of those things
into account that's why we're very clear
that the sums add up and uh allow us to
deliver the big increase to Neighborhood
policing whilst making sure that every
penny is well spent that making sure
that we make the savings that we need in
order to pay for it on the um the issue
kirstan was really clear about this that
we he was going to tackle the stain of
anti-Semitism in the labor party he was
going to be clear that labor has changed
and those big changes have taken place
since 2019 he's also been very very
clear with everyone what standards had
to be met and on everyone who wants to
stand as a labor candidate to be a labor
mp on what standards needed to be met
and he's making sure that that happens
and I pay tribute to Kia's leadership in
doing that the labor party has changed
we've come a long way in a short period
of time to be in in case words the party
of patriotism the party of equality also
crucially the party that plans to be in
government
thank you I'm going to turn now to some
questions that are coming in online from
the public and then we'll come to some
questions from the room so you you spoke
a bit about having tougher National
mandatory standards to tackle the
problem problems of culture and
standards in police forces can you say a
bit more about what specific problems
that would be to tackle and and how that
would actually achieve the sorts of
changes you're talking about yeah so
obviously the really awful cases of
David Carrick and Wayne cousins have
illuminated the failures in vetting
standards monitoring misconduct systems
and I think one of the most truly
shocking examples of all was in
um in July 2021 when complaints and
allegations were made of rape against
David Carrick that was a few months
after the awful murder of Sarah everard
it was at a time when the Met police and
all police forces were saying that they
were raising standards that they were
taking action and yet David Carrick was
not even suspended he was not suspended
at that time for a rape allegation and I
just find that truly shocking and what
is clear is that the the requirements on
police forces are two hit and miss it's
gives forces too much flexibility on
some of those basic things that should
be followed so yes we would have we
would introduce mandatory vetting
standards that all police forces have to
follow there's too much ability for them
to undercut or to reduce vetting
standards at the moment we would also
have a much stronger procedures around
misconduct as well for example making it
a requirement that facing officers who
face investigation for rape or domestic
abuse allegations should be suspended
and to have wider reforms around
training as well so we are working with
policing experts and with former Chief
constables on what the detail of what
those reforms would be but we think
those need to be underpinned in primary
legislation because I think the problem
is this is letting down victims but it's
also letting down hard-working police
officers you know who are doing
incredible jobs in many forces across
the country so that would be a priority
in terms of the legislative program
I've had a number of questions in about
charge rates you've talked about the
historic lows of charge rates um and
obviously that's particularly acute for
rape and sexual assault and you've
talked about
if you were to get into government how
you would aim to to increase those rates
can you say a little bit about how you
would do that but also about how you
would uh work through the knock-on
effects in the system of if that was
successful
um and and how you would not create
other problems within the system by
doing that yeah so
we this is the this really about
sometimes there's a bit it's about the
whole system and the the way it works
and Steve Reed is working on what needs
to be done across the court system to
speed things up including for example on
having Fast Track rape courses at courts
to deal with some of the serious issues
there but the there are obviously a
whole series of problems now in the
processes between policing and
prosecutors the some of the issues that
the officers who talked about the
redaction problems that they are facing
now that it's just not being dealt with
and is causing additional layers of
bureaucracy or time being spent in order
to lay charges some of the delays we've
lost CPS direct we've lost a lot of
those direct connections between the
police and prosecutors so what we are
doing is
um Emily Thornbury Steve Reed and I are
working together with again with a
former Chief constables prosecutors and
others on what that system should look
like in order to speed those processes
up and make it easier to lay charges
rather than ending up with officers
burdened by so much bureaucracy that
they end up not laying charges at all
thank you
um if you became homes secretary you'd
be inheriting a department which is in
the process of implementing a
transformation program uh in the in the
wake of the windruff Windrush Scandal do
you think ministers and civil servants
have been doing enough to address the
problems that were identified and do you
specifically think that the problems
that that program is tackling are the
right ones or do you think there are
deeper issues around the structure of
the home office and its responsibilities
which you would want to think about
so
I think there there are problems that I
was alluding to earlier about
um areas of work within the home office
having been either downgraded or almost
abandoned altogether so some of those
areas where it's the things that police
forces can't do alone it's the areas
where you need either National
leadership around policing or you need
National Partnerships with other
government departments so some of those
areas I think have been lost that
includes I mean look when we were in
government we had a lot of that
cross-depart departmental working was
immensely important I was a sure start
Minister for many years and we had a
cross-departmental committee that worked
very closely particularly to hold the
health and education department together
on working on tackling this I think a
lot of that cross-government working has
been lost I would like to see that
return and a home office that is outward
looking towards the rest of government
as well as towards community is across
the country the Windrush Scandal was
devastating it's terrible what happened
to British citizens to lawful residents
and the way in which they were treated
by the home office and the bunker
mentality that the home office got into
at that time and some of the things that
are really important was about the the
home office being responsive enough to
criticisms recognizing criticisms and
being able to respond rather than just
putting up barriers and refusing to
shift that is a culture change so some
of this is about structures and
Partnerships and so on some of it is
also about a culture change I think
Wendy Williams was clear that said that
not enough was being done to implement
her recommendations and we need to see I
hope stronger action in order to
implement those and I think there's
probably quite a lot of civil servants
in the home office who would really like
to see those changes take place and
would like to be part of that I mean
some people have argued that it doesn't
make sense for immigration to be
actually one of the home office's
responsibilities and that would be
better dealt with and better able to
take a broader view if it was a separate
Department what do you make of that
so I think you this look there's always
different mixes isn't there and some of
the issues around
um border security are also about Asylum
and also affect immigration issues as
well so there are always links and
overlaps and uh therefore I think the um
you know seeing that as being a is the
issue the problem is about the structure
of the home office and I think actually
the ish the real problems in these areas
have been about conservative government
policies and it's those policies that
ought to change
okay we're going to take some questions
from the room now can we begin with uh
Jessica Elgort from the guardian please
just wait for the
um
one
thanks so much hi Yvette
um I wonder if you think that the faith
in the metropolitan police can be
restored just by reform alone and if
there is if there are further scandals
in the police would a labor government
consider abolishing the Metropolitan
Police in the same way that the uh it
happened in Northern Ireland with the
psni in order to kind of restructure and
reform the organization and create a new
institution that had held public trust
thank you there's obviously different
circumstances because with psni there
was a particular recruitment issue about
the need to have a recruitment across
the communities
um in Northern Ireland so there's a
particular reason around that we are
very clear that confidence in the
metropolitan police has to be restored I
think the work that Mark Rowley and Lynn
Owens are doing is really important and
it's significant the things that they
have prioritized so the prioritize
raising standards and being very sort of
thorough and determined about going
after other cases where standards may
not have been met and where abuse may
have taken place and that means we would
expect to see more of those cases coming
to light other forces I think need to do
the same as that as well because this is
not just about the met the second thing
I think that's significant is the focus
on neighborhood policing and going back
to that neighborhood policing and having
I think Mark Rose words were more
neighborhood police officers than
they've had ever before that's Focus as
well and the third interestingly is
around technology and the use of new
technology where policing is hugely
outdated out of date we do expect to see
those reforms implemented but I think
the further questions for us
specifically about the Met will be
around what Louise Casey's review
reveals so we will wait I think to see
what that sets out as to see what
further reforms might be needed but I do
just say I think although the Met has
had particular issues there are wider
issues around making sure that we deal
with standards and with confidence in
all police forces and that's why you
need home office leadership not just the
work that is happening in London
thank you do you have Jack Elson from
the Sun
thank you very much um you talked about
ways about how we can
um root out polling cases like David
Carrick and Wayne cousins can you give
us just some specific examples about how
you would strengthen those tests when it
comes to vetting to stop these police
officers ever becoming part of the force
so at the moment there's uh it's
possible for police officers to get
through the whole stages of the
recruitment without ever being
interviewed in person and without having
employment references checked or
character references checked that's not
good enough this is policing there are
much more robust checks on people for
all kinds of different jobs than there
are for one of the most important jobs
that there is the social media checks
that take place there are cases where
forces have found actually there was
some quite troubling
um things being said by a potential
officer by a candidate in on their
social media and instead of taking that
as an indication of something that might
be of concern and might be a reason not
to recruit someone fine go get another
job maybe all sorts of other jobs you'd
be great at doing but not to be a police
officer that is not taken seriously
enough and it was also just dismissed as
part of the recruitment process so I
think there are proper checks that
should be being done proper standards
that should be being there and also
proper training you know a much stronger
the process of training around making
sure those standards are met and then
having standards then in if if
allegations or concerns are raised the
point I said earlier about you know if
you've got an officer facing a rape
allegation
um or a domestic abuse allegation that's
being investigated by their Force they
should be suspended and I've seen cases
for example where of someone who is a
police officer who faced domestic abuse
allegations the police force took it
sufficiently seriously that they took
that case to court they took that
officer to court for prosecution but
throughout that time the officer was not
suspended
I just don't think that is good enough
and so that's why I think you have to
have stronger mandatory standards in
place
I'm going to start taking questions in
pairs now just to make sure we can get
through enough so can I go to the times
and then to PA
let's come out here from the times no
okay straight to PA then
thank you very much
um so after your announcement today home
office Minister Chris philba said that
Labor's proposed investment is a tenth
of what the Tories are delivering and
also you mentioned the 20 000 police
officers I wanted to ask you what you
say to that and then my second question
I just have one question we've got a lot
to get through thank you that's right
could we go to the Daily Mirror
nope okay in which case Daily Telegraph
no
uh okay then the I is Chloe here for now
yep thank you
thank you Chloe Chapman from the eye I
just wanted to touch on something that
you mentioned earlier do you think under
this home office there's been too much
political capital and time and money
spent on tackling immigration at the
expense of tackling crime and do you
think that they've misinterpreted what
voters really care more about and also I
wondered if you could set a bit of a
timeline out for these policies
um so I'll start with the
um the conservative ministers I mean
seriously they you know all they are
doing is belatedly trying to reverse the
cuts that they made the 20 000 cuts that
they made to policing and that is still
even despite them doing that it's still
not restoring neighborhood policing so
our proposals are on top of the
government's reversing of cuts our
proposals go much further and we're
talking about rebuilding and renewing
neighborhood policing because the
problem is even where they've tried to
reverse the damage that they did it's
still not restored in neighborhood
policing it's still not getting the
neighborhood teams and that's this stock
fact about only 12 of police officers
are now in neighborhood teams it was 19
in 2010 and that's been a big shift in
the kind of in the way in which policing
operates it is more of the reactive
policing that we've seen I understand
there's reasons for that around some of
the growing mental health demand which
is why that should be tackled as well
but I just you know I think the
conservatives have you know they have
done huge damage to confidence in
policing to confidence in the criminal
justice system and they've just stood
back while all this has happened they
have stood back well the charge rates
have plummeted they've stood back while
victims are being denied Justice we
still haven't got a victims Bill and
they've stood back one more all
criminals are getting off I think they
are really weak on crime and its causes
and you know I don't think many people
take seriously what Chris philp is
saying
other questions about are they folks so
the in the end of the home office look
all of these issues are important and
they should be able to do both they
should be able to have a focus around
crime policing and also on issues around
immigration
um there the issues around the Boat
Crossings The Boat Crossings are
dangerous and are putting lives at risk
so that has to be an issue that the home
office makes an important priority again
it comes back to that broader
responsibility that home office has
around security and Public Safety those
are the things that we should focus on
um I um actually would also see more
Focus around some of the National
Security issues as well I think those
are important too
thank you we've got uh someone here from
the ft
thank you
Robert Wright from the AFT
um clearly it's going to be far easier
for you to implement some of these
policies if you've got a secure majority
and some people are suggesting that
developments in Scotland with the
resignation of the first Minister could
be uh stepped towards uh your to make it
far easier for you to get a substantial
majority the coming general election I'm
just wondering what you would say about
that
um I think I would probably first say
um recognize the
the long period of time that Nicholas
sturgeon has given in public service
terms and and pay tribute to that wish
her well for the future but I do also
hope that this is a reset moment for
Scottish politics and that the focus can
now be rather than always being around
separation rather than going around the
same arguments again and again can be
instead around the issues of the cost of
living crisis the state of the National
Health Service under the SMP in Scotland
the problems in schools in Scotland
those are the issues that anasawa and
Scottish labor have been raising and
highlighting and I think that their work
on us and others have been doing has
been rebuilding support in Scotland
we're working really hard to focus on
those sorts of issues and what labor can
do and to help people across Scotland on
those crucial issues just something like
the energy price freeze those sorts of
things as well
okay do we have Jessica from cityam
no in which case I'd like to take a
question that's come through from a
civil servant online
um who says I've worked in a few private
offices the Civil Service isn't perfect
but gets a lot of blame when ministers
do not know how to pull levers
effectively how should the home office
change to deliver better
so
um the I think there'll obviously have
been quite a lot of changes in the way
that government departments work
um compared to 13 years ago
um but I think
um my experience always of working with
civil servants was the number of
dedicated people working immensely hard
and you know doing their best to deliver
the priorities of the minister of the
day
um I think there's been a damaging
tendency over the last few years for
conservative ministers to almost want to
try and ignore the facts and ignore
evidence that puts civil servants often
in a very difficult position
and you have to respect the evidence and
that was the approach we would take to
be very evidence based in our way of
working I do also think that there's
um issues some of this is about
ministers being very clear about what
the priorities are that is I know the
approach that care would take
um leading a labor government and it's
also the approach that I would take as a
labor Home Secretary so part of that is
about the priorities and purpose for the
department but it's also about that
cross-government working that I don't
see any real evidence of compared to the
kinds of programs and Partnerships that
we used to have in place and when I
talked about active government before
and active government working in
Partnership this is not just about crime
and policing this is a philosophy for
labor because if you listen to Johnny
Reynolds talking about Labor's
industrial policy it's the same thing
that he's talking about in terms of
getting economic growth and working in
partnership with business in partnership
with trade unions in partnership with
organizations across the country so the
government does its bit but in
Partnership rather than government
trying to do everything or rather than
government just walking away it's the
same approach on crime and policing and
home Affairs as well I wanted to dig
into that idea a bit actually because
almost by definition the home office is
the department which tends to be most
reactive most having to respond to
crises so how does this active
government approach work how do you get
ahead of the sorts of problems which
tend to crop up in the home office well
sorry for example in policing If part of
the problem is over 13 years the
technology that the police use has
fallen further and further behind
leaving that process to 43 forces to
coordinate has not worked it has not
delivered them the kinds of technology
that they need and Dennis O'Connor when
he was the Chief Inspector of policing
some years ago said to me you know when
he'd started work as a as a copper in
the 1970s he said look we've been
policing we were ahead of the game we
had the best technology going we had far
better technology than communities than
criminals because they had the police
radio systems in place now and he said
that this you know nearly a decade ago
said now the police are being left
behind that Gap has got even further now
over the last 10 years but where's the
leadership been from the home office
around something like that where's the
leadership been on Workforce strategies
and making sure you have the skills and
the modern Workforce and that's why I
mean I suppose about in the end the home
office has to take some responsibility
if public services are going wrong you
might want them to be doing this on
their own but if they are not if it is
not happening you have to take some
responsibility as a conservative Home
Secretary suareman has totally failed to
do that but so have her predecessors and
that's why I think this is about a
conservative philosophy of government
and an approach not just individual
failure and incompetence
thank you I think we've got time for a
couple more questions in the room
muddy the gentleman at the back with the
glasses
uh Tom Windsor formerly of the
inspectorate are your proposals not a
wee bit modest
um thirteen thousand pairs of brutes on
the ground
uh divided by three shifts is 4300
divided by 43 forces is a hundred more
per force on average would the money not
be better spent on the investment and
Technology you make the points
powerfully I've done the same as you
know the National Crime agency has some
superb technology and yet they only have
three or four people working on it and
if they had more investment they could
do far far more and that technology
could be shared with all the other
police forces it doesn't just have to be
serious and organized crime
you made the point that you can have new
legislation on standards but you don't
need it under Section 53-a sorry to be
technical you already have that power
you could set those standards on the
first day
standards on pretty much anything
including vetting but also neighborhood
policing and many other things
so those are my observations my question
is
with the home office leaning in more and
the current set of ministers use that
phrase too
are you going to respect the operational
Independence of the police
so I think Tom there were four questions
there
um uh so I um I agree with you that on
standards there are things that the Home
Secretary can do straight away so there
are some areas where you would actually
be able to make changes rapidly we also
think that primary legislation would
help as well to underpin it but I do
agree with you there are some things
where you can also just directly mandate
things and make certain changes
immediately as well as having I think it
does need now a new standards framework
that should be properly legislated for
and properly underpinned as well so that
it doesn't become a sort of ad hoc
process of a Home Secretary using powers
in an ad hoc way I think better to have
something systematic to underpin it
secondly on the
um the technology versus people things
there is clearly far more that can be
done and far more can be done in terms
of effective technology that is a mix of
both partly around the coordination of
Technology partly around the
introduction of new technology and
partly around making sure that officers
have the skills to use the technology
and that includes some of that will be
about staff as well because some of that
is not just about the work officers need
to do it's about the data analysis and
those sorts of things to properly get
you know hot spot-led policing or
different kinds of targeted and
evidence-driven issues on the the
approach the neighborhood policing
though I would say just two things first
of all I don't think technology is a
substitute for people and for building
relationships and that's the most
important thing about the neighborhood
policing that it does differently to
other areas of policing it's about
building the relationships the pcso I
spoke to in Milton Keynes yesterday you
know just has he's been in that same
area of Milton Keynes for 15 years and
has built up huge relationships with
local people about where the problems
are about the things that go wrong about
the things that need to be done to put
things right and that kind of
intelligence and that kind of confidence
that those relationships build is
immensely important the proposals we
have put forward will mean in many areas
actually about 50 increase in the level
of neighborhood policing that they have
currently got so you're right that
Services have been very stretched but
this still is a very significant
increase in neighborhood policing and
we're also talking about having the the
kind of guarantee in place that
underpins it as well in terms of the
operational Independence absolutely
operational Independence is immensely
important when it comes to dealing with
individual cases that is a matter for
the police they have to take the
decisions about the investigations that
are needed and so on and that also means
about recognizing the different demands
on Public Safety that they have to take
decisions on as well but you know
coordination of a computer system that
means that the you know the CPS who
cover a range of different police forces
can't even use the same technology
systems for the whole of the CPS region
because each police force has got a
different system for communicating on
the files and that is just Bonkers and
so it really should be possible to have
that proper coordination and to insist
that police forces do that and not to
think that frankly the having their own
particular set of software or their own
particular computer is somehow
significant to operational Independence
because it's not it's actually about
operational effectiveness for all forces
working together
because I'm afraid that's all we've got
time for so when you join me in thanking
a bit for a very content-rich and
interesting uh speech today
and just a quick reminder the live
stream will be on our website in the
next few days thank you very much to
everyone for joining us and if you would
like to join us for our next public
event that will be on the 23rd of
February and will be on the spring
budget and pressures on public services
so do join us for that
[Music]